NATHAN: Michael is the
founder of the Metta Center,
a center that works
on nonviolence issues,
and also was a professor
at Berkeley, teaching for--
how many years was it, Michael?
MICHAEL NAGLER: Oh, you sure--
47 years.
NATHAN: 47 years teaching peace
and nonviolence at Berkeley.
I was lucky to attend
his class in 2005,
and it had an extremely
big impact on my life
and got me involved in working
in nonviolence, becoming
a community organizer,
starting to meditate.
And so Michael's been
a huge teacher for me
and I'm really excited to
for him to come to Google.
But yeah, without any
other further ado,
I'd love to introduce
you to Michael Nagler.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL NAGLER: Thank
you very much, Nathan.
I'm really, really pleased
to be here with you today.
And I'd like to start off by
sharing with you the trailer
of a documentary film that I've
been working on for more years
than I would like to
think about right now.
But it looks like we're kind of
getting closer to completion.
We started this film
for a couple of reasons.
You may have-- can I
get a show of hands?
How many of you have seen
Richard Attenborough's film,
"Gandhi"?
OK.
I would highly recommend
it for all of you.
It's mostly accurate.
What it omits-- two things.
It omits any exploration
of Gandhi's spirituality,
and it omits any of
those big conversion
moments that happened when a
person encounters nonviolence
and changes.
In our workshop this
afternoon, Stephanie
is going to share with us some
very dramatic episodes where
this happened.
But there were many, many
episodes in Gandhi's life
where somebody was about
to strike him and--
there was even an episode
where somebody was choking him.
He had sworn to kill Gandhi, so
Gandhi went there right away,
knocked on the door
and said, I'm here
to help you fulfill your vow.
And the man started
choking him and Gandhi just
looked him in the eye
without a trace of fear.
And after about half a
minute, he dropped his hands,
fell at his feet and
said, you are now
in charge of this whole village.
So that was missing.
Then there's been some
recent documentaries
which touched on one
nonviolent episode or another.
So there's an
excellent film on the--
come on in-- on the
Otpor revolution that
took place in Serbia in 2000.
How many of you have
heard of that ever?
OK, very good.
This is Google.
And there's films about
the civil rights movement.
Of course, there's films about
the Indian freedom struggle.
But I don't know of any film
that steps back and says,
what is nonviolence?
Where does it stand
right now, where
do we go with it from here,
and what can I do about it?
which is what we're going to
be talking about here today.
So without further
ado-- and by the way,
we're also, in case
you're not aware of it,
we're also exploiting you
as good labor practice
because we would like to get
your feedback on the film.
OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BERNARD LAFAYETTE: Nonviolence,
to me, is a source of power.
And the power is
actually in each person.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID HARTSOUGH: Toward
the end of the second day,
I was meditating on
loving your enemy.
And I heard a guy
come up from behind me
and he says, if
you don't get out
of this store in
two seconds, I'm
going to stab this
through your heart.
And I had two seconds
to decide, well,
do I really believe
in nonviolence
or is there any other way I
should relate to this guy?
TIFFANY TOOL: I learned
about nonviolence
in the backwards
way, as in I really
focused on the practical
use of nonviolence
prior to learning the
theory of nonviolence.
And it started when I was
working with Peace Brigades
International in Indonesia.
GREGORY OTIENO: It
doesn't mean that I'm
weak if I turn the other cheek.
It means that I'm
not just distracted
by the violent nature
of the other people.
I look up to more
deeper meaning to life.
MICHAEL NAGLER: Well, like
many people, when I first heard
about nonviolence and became
aware of what Gandhi was doing,
I said, I can't do that.
There are disciplines
that a person can practice
that helps you deal with
the strong emotions that
are going to come up
in a serious conflict.
KEN BUTIGAN: So
we are continually
inviting people to
really work with the two
hands of nonviolence.
The two hands of nonviolence
being on the one hand,
I will not cooperate with your
injustice, but I'm open to you
as a human being.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DR. FRANS DE WAAL:
Veneer theory basically
says that, deep down, we humans,
we are nasty and selfish.
And if we are civil and kind to
each other, it's just a veneer.
It's a thin veneer of morality.
And I've always
protested against that
because I think it's a
simplification of human nature.
DR. ELISABET
SAHTORIS: I discovered
that there was a cycle
of maturation going on
in evolution over and over.
The first great
leap in evolution
was competition to cooperation
in nucleated cells.
The second leap was
competition to cooperation
into multi-celled creatures.
DR. RACHEL MACNAIR: Killing
tends to make us mentally ill.
It tends to make us sick.
DR. ERICA CHENOWETH: Yeah,
one of the big myths that's
busted through our data is
that nonviolent resistance
takes longer to achieve results
than violent insurgency.
In fact, what we find is
strikingly the opposite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL NAGLER:
Humanity, as a whole,
is becoming aware of
nonviolence and that this
is a tremendous
potential breakthrough.
RIVERA SUN: You know,
there's a famous story
about Emmett Till's mother.
Emmett Till was a
14-year-old black boy
from Chicago area,
I believe, who
whistled at a white woman in the
South while visiting his cousin
and ended up being lynched
and thrown in the river.
Years later, when his actual
murderers were put to trial,
someone asked Emmett
Till's mother,
would you like to see them
get the death penalty?
And she said no.
If I could, if I had a choice
in this justice system,
I would take their children
and raise them as my own
so they would learn to love.
KEN BUTIGAN: Not easy to do
it, but this creative tension
between saying no and
saying yes, this is the job
description of the 21st century.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL NAGLER: So I'd like
to, when you recovered,
ask for any comments
you have, any
questions you have about the
trailer, what it presents.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: I think it
does its job because it
makes me want to learn more.
MICHAEL NAGLER: I think
that's about the best
comment I think we could hear.
Yeah, that is the point.
The motto, mantra, if you
will, of the Metta Center
is helping people
practice nonviolence more
safely and more effectively.
We're fundamentally an
educational institution
because we feel that
people do not get a chance
to find out about this power,
as Bernard Lafayette calls it,
which is, as he said--
he may not have
said it right here,
but I think it's the most
important power, the most
defining power that we can
draw upon as human beings.
Now, I wonder how
many of you are
familiar with the
term the New Story?
You might call it
Western civilization 2.0.
What's happening
is we are actually
in a very awkward situation.
This is why there is so much
violence and disruption going
on in our world.
It's not because we have only
a thin veneer of morality.
Stephanie and I,
and Metta Center,
are up in smoke country
and the north counties
and the outpouring of
support and volunteers
has been absolutely
overwhelming.
We got a call a couple
of days ago from somebody
who wanted to donate clothing
to us because she had tried
to donate them to
all the centers
that had evacuees in them and
they weren't taking any more.
They had mountains and
mountains of clothing.
In fact, Lou, who is
doing the film with us,
spent the whole day sorting
through mountains of clothing
so that evacuees or anybody
else could come and get them.
So it was this huge
outpouring of compassion
that was immediately
touched when
our community, our
neighborhood, was in crisis.
But there was a
study, or an article,
recently about the fact
that we are experiencing
an epidemic of depression.
We've got our share
of epidemics going on.
We've got an opioid epidemic.
There's an epidemic of suicides
among military personnel.
Might get back to
that in a little bit.
And there's an
epidemic of depression.
All of those things are symptoms
of this great awkwardness
I'm going to say a
word about in a minute.
And this author said that
that is a misdiagnosis.
It's not really depression
that we're dealing with.
What we're dealing
with is demoralization.
There's demoralization because--
this is where the New Story
comes in--
we're operating with a model of
reality in our mind which is--
the three things to be
said about it, aside
from the fact that it's been
there for a couple hundred
years now, it is demoralizing,
it is extremely harmful,
and it's dead wrong.
And that model-- which I'm
going to show you some examples
of how it's shared everywhere--
is that we're all
material beings
and we're determined by
mindless forces, everything
from genes to cosmic rays
to hormones and so forth.
We have no control over
our destiny, right?
So we have to respond to every
advertisement and signal that
comes down the line.
And we basically have no
meaning on this planet.
Now, you may not believe
that, and I congratulate you
for seeing through the fog.
But the fact is that
this is the model which
is operational for most people.
You do not have to prove it.
If you assume it, you can
simply refer back to it,
and people are supposed
to follow along with you.
So the next thing I'd
like to show you--
which may need some help
from Maria, not sure--
is an animation that we've done
to illustrate this shift that's
going on to the New Story.
And so in order to not
keep you in suspense--
I can almost sense the
rising tension in the room--
the New Story, as hinted
at by those scientists
that you just saw
in the trailer--
and we have several of
them in the finished film--
is that in fact, we are
body, mind, and spirit.
And just to paraphrase
the New Testament,
we are body, mind, and spirit.
All three of these, but
spirit is the most important.
And we are deeply
interconnected with one another,
such that if I were to do
something to injure Ziggy,
let's say, which is
absolutely unthinkable.
But let's say I were to
do something like that.
The fact is, I'd be
hurting myself more
than I'd be hurting you.
And that's why all of
our military personnel,
there's this huge drumbeat.
You're telling them, oh, you're
so wonderful, you're so great,
you're saving our country.
Well, the President
doesn't say that,
but the culture as a
whole is saying that.
Look, there's lots of seats
here if you'd like to come in.
There's enough
violence in the world
without you having to eat
your lunch standing up.
They're being told officially
that what they're doing
is honorific and glorious
and helpful and wonderful.
But inside they know
that it's a damn lie.
And if you ask
them, they will say,
I felt like I lost
my soul in Iraq,
or I don't like myself anymore.
20 people a day committing
suicide for this reason.
By stark contrast, people who've
been practicing nonviolence
have a very different
story to tell.
And there was a person
in Iraqi Kurdistan,
actually, who said to
a person who was there
from this country, from a group
called Christian Peacemaker
Teams, which is part of this
new institution that's sprung up
called Unarmed Civilian
Peacekeeping or protection,
Unarmed Civilian Protection.
This Kurdish
gentleman said, well,
we're going to try and do it
from here out with nonviolence.
And the person from
Christian Peacemaker Teams
said, you know, you can
do that if you want to,
but it's very difficult,
which is true.
It can be dangerous,
which is an exaggeration,
and it takes more time,
which is not true at all,
we just found out.
And he said, I know
all of those things,
but you don't lose your
soul in the process.
You don't lose your
humanity in the process.
So I like to present this
as a stark contrast which
illustrates the impact of
operating on the wrong story
and letting it draw
you into action
and operating on the New Story,
despite the fact that nobody
knows what the heck
you're trying to do.
So we feel that the
development of the New Story
and the development
of nonviolence
go hand-in-hand, like opposite
sides of the same coin.
The New Story will
never be complete.
We feel-- we being
basically me and Stephanie--
we feel, at Metta, that the New
Story will never be complete
until it makes this discovery
that this film is driving
at that the capacity
to be nonviolent
is the core of our
human identity.
So when you are
nonviolent, you feel
that you are closer
to fulfilling yourself
as a human being.
That's why the subtitle of
the working title of the film
is nonviolence
and human destiny.
And on the other
hand, nonviolence,
as I'm going to be
showing in a bit,
is very difficult
to grasp if you've
got that old story, that
old paradigm, or model
in your mind.
OK.
So here is the animation
that we created.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Are you looking for happiness?
Who isn't?
In order to be happy, we
need to feel safe, too.
But how do we find
peace and happiness?
Every day, we're flooded by
messages telling us who we are
and what makes us
secure and happy.
It sounds a bit like this.
Happiness equals buying
things and security
equals punishing crime.
Let's call this the Old Story.
It shows a rather uninspiring
picture of human kind,
but does it work?
Does buying stuff
actually make us happy?
Are punishment and revenge
really making us secure?
The answer is no.
Studies show that once
people have the basics,
wealth doesn't add to
happiness, but even reduces it.
Also, huge incarceration rates
eventually lead to more crime.
And as a military commander
in Iraq once said,
we're making terrorists
faster than we can kill them.
The good news is that,
for the last 30 years,
science has been telling us
an entirely different and much
better story.
For example, our brains
reward us powerfully
when we do something
selfless for others.
It gives us a strong sense
of meaning and fulfillment,
key elements of true happiness.
In fact, we're
wired for empathy.
Our mirror neurons respond
sensitively to what others do,
think, and feel.
We're more connected to
each other than we think.
This positive view on
humankind is the New Story.
And if you listen well,
you can hear it everywhere
under many names.
It's the story where ancient
wisdom and modern research
come together.
This story says that much
happiness is within us
after all, so we don't need
to consume our planet trying
to get it from the outside.
It also says that
real security doesn't
come from violence
and punishment,
but from ensuring that
everyone has what they need,
including love and respect.
The New Story isn't
that new at all.
It looks like the wisest
among us were right all along.
As Martin Luther King said
in his famous Nobel Prize
acceptance speech--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING,
JR.: Man must evolve,
for all human conflict,
a method which
rejects revenge,
aggression, and retaliation.
The foundation of
such a method is love.
[END PLAYBACK]
- OK.
That's all very touching, but
what about crime and violence?
How do we deal with that?
Well, in lots of ways.
For example, have you heard
of restorative justice?
This method involves
victim, offender,
and the whole community.
It's effective,
cheap, and it builds
community in the process.
And did you know that
ordinary citizens
with nonviolence training
are solving conflicts
all over the world?
It shows we can do things so
much differently and better
if we change the narrative.
The New Story has new heroes.
Here, we're not consumers,
but contributors.
What really makes us happy
is finding our unique gifts
and giving them to the world.
At the Metta Center, we
believe in the New Story.
We all have a role to play
in making it come true.
If you are up to the
task, we can help you.
Our website offers
lots of free resources
to help you learn the New Story.
We've even built a roadmap
to get you started.
Want to be a part of this story?
Share it with others.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL NAGLER: So I hope
that serves as an introduction
to this new paradigm.
And our feeling of late is that
the shift from the Old Story,
which isn't working, to a new
one, which has not yet adopted,
is kind of stuck.
It hasn't been moving very much.
I first got exposed to this
when I was beginning my career
at the university in 1970,
handed around these little
mimeograph-- you
don't remember those--
sheets talking about
the prevailing paradigm,
the dominance paradigm, a.k.a.
the Old Story, and the
emerging paradigm, a.k.a.
the New Story.
But it still hasn't
emerged, despite the fact
that we have this great
wisdom tradition, which is now
available to all of us,
and despite the fact
that science is now
confirming this dramatically.
So for example, we
mentioned briefly,
in the animation, the
concept of mirror neurons.
Have you heard of those?
OK.
So do you want to tell us?
AUDIENCE: There's some
controversy about what
they actually mean, but--
MICHAEL NAGLER: Yes.
Well, there's controversy
about everything,
but one aspect of it
is that, for example,
if somebody is writing,
the motor neurons that
would make me write are
fired just by observing that,
even though I'm
not writing myself.
At the last minute,
there's another set
of neurons, which intersects
that process and says,
you're not Ziggy, so you
don't have to go like this.
Now, that's, of
course, critically
important for nonviolence
because in nonviolence,
the power comes from being able
to, as we call it nowadays,
flip the switch.
Somebody comes at
you with a threat.
The script is,
you're supposed to be
going into fear and compliance.
But as Ken Butigan showed
you in the trailer,
you say instead, I refuse to
go along with your coercion,
but I accept--
I'm open to you
as a human being.
And you flip that script.
So when I completely
change my mental state,
your mirror neurons
resonate with that.
It doesn't, 100% of the
time, mean that you're
going to change your behavior.
But it does mean that
more often and more safely
than if you try to
get a person to change
through threat of violence.
So any-- this is my whole career
I'm condensing into one hour,
so I know I'm
going kind of fast.
If you have any questions, let
me pause here briefly to see.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about
that last point about--
you're saying
flipping the switch,
changing the dynamics
of the situation.
MICHAEL NAGLER:
Flipping the script.
AUDIENCE: Flipping
the script, sorry.
MICHAEL NAGLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You know,
in psychology, there's
also discussion about
sociopaths, people
who would perceive the
emotions of others,
but don't experience that
kind of empathic response.
How do you account for that
or how do you respond to that?
MICHAEL NAGLER: Right.
What do you do with
a real sociopath?
Well, that's going
to be hard, and it's
going to be a lot harder
than with a normally
empathic person.
But it turns out that even
there, it's not impossible.
And when we do the
workshop right after this,
we'll show you some
examples of that.
Because what you're doing is
actually appealing to something
even deeper than that
sociopathology, which has been
conditioned into the person.
Something inside of
them which they are not
even consciously aware of.
In fact, that's
one of the reasons
that nonviolence is such
a powerful contributor
to positive social change.
It elicits things from
people that they're not
even aware is there.
I have a very dear
friend whose parents
were in the
underground in Warsaw
during the Nazi occupation.
And a Gestapo came
to their apartment
and found these
incriminating papers,
was about to arrest them.
Needless to say here,
Jewish in the underground.
But this couple had
a four-year-old boy
and he was fascinated by
the buttons on the Gestapo
captain's uniform.
So to the horror of
the parents, here he
is playing with these buttons.
The captain looked down and
suddenly, he just completely
changed.
He said, I have a little boy
at home who is just his age.
And he said, I miss
him-- excuse me--
I miss him very much.
And then he ordered his
men to leave the apartment.
And then the couple
survived the war
and actually became the parents
of a very good friend of mine
who's in the peace movement.
So what we do in
nonviolence is we
learn the techniques to elicit
that change deliberately.
We will go into that
in the workshop.
Good.
Any other comments
before I roll on?
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
question about the trailer
that you just showed us
and general questions
about a reformative justice.
I'm happy to wait if
that's something that's
going to be featured
in your talk,
but otherwise I'll
go ahead and ask.
I mean, is reformative justice--
MICHAEL NAGLER:
Restorative justice?
AUDIENCE: Restorative justice.
MICHAEL NAGLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that something
that you're going to touch upon
during the course of the talk?
MICHAEL NAGLER: Now that
you brought it up, sure.
Yes, I'd be happy to.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL NAGLER: Restorative
justice is based on the idea
that when there's
been what is otherwise
called a crime, what's
actually at issue is harm.
Not a crime in law, but
harm to human relationships.
And you want to restore
that relationship.
You don't do that by locking the
person who offended you away.
You make it impossible to
restore that relationship.
So you bring them back in
and set up a safe zone where
they can say two things.
They can say here's
why I did it.
And sometimes, these people
have horrendous stories of abuse
in their background,
which changes
the atmosphere a little bit.
And then they take
responsibility
and say, what can I do?
A lot of this
restorative behavior
has been practiced in indigenous
cultures for a long time.
And in one case that I
find really dramatic,
there is a large community
in sub-Saharan Africa called
the Bemba.
And when somebody offends
in that community,
they are made to sit in a
circle with the whole village
around them.
And they go around that circle
and everyone in the village
is required to say something
good about that person.
And when they get about
halfway around the circle,
usually the person, the guy--
it's almost always a guy--
breaks down and has a
complete change of heart,
and then they work
out a restitution
for the harm that's been done,
and they rebuild the community.
So we were in a meeting in
the Santa Rosa school system
not long ago where they had
introduced restorative justice
in the schools, and the
expulsion and suspension rate
went from 60 cases to
two in the first year.
It was on its way to being zero.
There was one
educator down south,
San Diego, who was
completely against this--
it would never
work in my school.
It's way too tough.
And he's now one of
the biggest supporters.
And I asked him, what
was the big change?
And he said, every time
I did the normal system,
I lost a relationship.
That's because that's what the
"normal," unquote, system does.
Every time I do restorative
justice, I gain a relationship.
So we have a long range
program at Metta Center
to try to get restorative
justice into the schools.
And then when it's really
established in the schools,
get it into the prisons.
And when it's
established in there,
we could get it anywhere.
We could get rid of
the whole war system.
So as Martin Luther
King would say,
I may not get there with
you, but it is a very good
trajectory to work on.
OK.
So let me now take us
a little bit deeper
into what nonviolence is.
And these have been
very good questions,
so please keep them coming.
So this is just our
introductory slide,
helping people practice
nonviolence more
safely and more effectively.
I think you know that gentleman
with the spinning wheel.
So I wanted to illustrate what
the Old Story is doing to us.
This is a billboard
that was not far
from our office in Petaluma.
And I wanted to emphasize
the motto in red
at the top of this billboard,
"Our Pain is Your Gain."
In other words, if you can
make us suffer, you win.
You'll be advancing
yourself by putting us down.
Now, let me project this
against a model that
was developed by one of the
greatest peace researchers
that we had in the English
language, Kenneth Boulding.
And towards the end
of his life, Kenneth
wrote a book called "The
Three Faces of Power."
He said we have three
ways of getting a person
to do something,
otherwise known as power.
There is threat power, where
essentially you're saying,
do what I want or I'll do
something you don't want.
There's exchange power, where
essentially you're saying,
give me something
I want and I'll
give you something you want.
And finally, but the
most important and least
studied, is one called
integrative power,
where you say, I am
going to be authentic
and we will end up closer.
Now, exchange power is kind of
in a middle zone between threat
power, which is
clearly violence,
and integrative power,
which is nonviolence.
And you can run exchange
power in both ways.
Here, we have an example
of exchange power
being used to create
violence on a subtle level.
While it's selling
you some real estate,
it is also selling you
on the Old Story idea
that in order for
you to be happy,
somebody else probably
has to suffer.
I promise you the
tour of the Old Story
is not going to be too long.
We'll get to nonviolence soon.
But here's another
subtle example of it.
The reason this
offends me so much--
may not offend you--
is that inner peace is
a very important concept
and to trivialize it with the
idea of outer purchasing--
and we've gotten inured to this.
It goes on and on.
But my PhD was in a subject
called comparative literature,
so I'm very sensitive
to what people are
being told under the surface.
It's subtler and more
powerful than what they're
being told on the surface.
So on the surface, you're being
told buy a Dell hard drive.
Don't want to mention
brand names here.
Under the surface,
they're saying--
as we said, it's showed
in the animation--
the way to happiness
is through purchases.
In other words, there is
no happiness within you,
which is a huge lie.
OK.
So this is probably a stark
statement of the New Story.
When you want real wisdom in
this world, where do you go?
You go to bumper
stickers, right?
There was a bumper sticker in
my part of town a while back
which said, "My wife says
I don't listen to her.
At least I think
that's what she said."
And this one says, "We are
not human beings having
a spiritual experience"-- which
you will hear every other day
in Marin County--
"we are spiritual beings
having a human experience."
In other words, we
are fundamentally
a spirit who have
entered a human context.
Again, I'm moving
very fast, so please
feel free to stick your
hand up or jot down
a question for later.
Now, in the trailer,
you saw an interview
with a woman named
Erica Chenoweth.
To back up a second,
back in the '70s,
there was a book
by a couple called
Lind, Staughton and
Alice Lind, called
"Nonviolence in America."
That's an arresting
title, to be sure.
And yes, it was a full
book, believe it or not,
with actual content and a
table of contents and an index
and all of those good things.
You get a PhD on this stuff.
And one of the things that
they said in their introduction
to the book is the way
that social science
has ignored this story and let
it disappear is a disgrace.
So fortunately, in just
the last few years--
just the last few years--
this has changed.
And Erica Chenoweth
and Maria Stephan
have written a very
compelling book called
"Why Civil Resistance Works."
They're using the word civil
resistance for nonviolence.
And just to summarize
some of their discoveries,
they explored almost
300 cases of what
we call insurrectionary
movements, regime
change through uprisings.
And if they were
violent, they were
successful 26% of the time.
If they were nonviolent,
meaning weapon-free, so forth--
depending on strikes and
non-cooperation techniques,
things of that kind--
they were successful
56% of the time.
If they were violent,
they took 9 to 10 years
to run their course,
usually ending up
in a battle of attrition,
kind of a civil war.
If they were nonviolent, it
took from two to three years.
And they were more likely to
lead to democratic conditions
five years down the road,
even if they, quote, "failed."
Failed, that is to say,
to overthrow a dictator
or whatever it was
they were aiming at.
So you overthrow a
dictator through violence,
you don't get a
free civilization.
As Gandhi said-- he kept
coming to Gandhi and saying,
when are you going to stop
with this nonviolent stuff
and get to the real revolution?
And he said, violent
revolution will
lead to violence [INAUDIBLE],,
a violent regime.
A nonviolent revolution will
lead to a nonviolent regime,
even if it "fails,"
quote, unquote, to do
what you were trying to do.
I can expand on any
of these points,
but I think, for now, I'm
just trying to introduce you
to the scope of things.
So this gives us an
idea of what nonviolence
looked like in the Old Story.
And we usually, today, call
that strategic nonviolence.
And what it looks like in the
New Story, and that's called
principled nonviolence.
So we'll take this one episode.
This is an uprising in Yemen.
You can see those people
are pretty agitated.
And they had a
slogan, which was,
"They can't defeat us because
we left our weapons at home."
Now, that is basically true.
It turns out that
if you use weapons,
you're actually
producing violence.
Something like 70% of
homicides these days
are what's called victim
precipitated homicides.
You pull out a weapon to defend
yourself, you get blown away.
So I'm not disputing
the truth of that,
but in strategic
nonviolence, you
look at a person as a rational,
cost benefit calculator
and try to, more or
less, force that person
to do what you want by
changing conditions.
Whereas in principled
nonviolence,
you might have said, "We
will win them over"--
instead of "they
can't defeat us."
"We will win them over because
we left our hatred at home."
And that's why it is difficult
to understand real nonviolence
in the Old Story because
we do not acknowledge
the power of inner states.
So here's someone who
acknowledged them.
And this is one of the
most important statements
in the history of nonviolence.
"I have learnt the one supreme
lesson to conserve my anger,
and as heat conserved is
transmuted into energy,
our anger controlled can be
transmuted into a power that
can move the world."
One other little
complaint that I
have about Richard
Attenborough's film
is it does not show you
how angry Gandhi was.
Oh, my gosh, was he angry.
But he had something to do with
it, and not just let it out,
which is a huge mistake that's
done with many movements today.
A lot of people think
that all they need to do
is show others how
angry they are,
and they will have
made their point.
Well, given the mirror
neurons, if you show people
how angry they are, they'll
get much more angry at you.
And where do you go?
So because this
is so important, I
like to dwell on it
just a little bit more.
"Civil disobedience," a part
of one of the nonviolent
strategies, "is a
sovereign method
of transforming undisciplined,
life-destroying latent energy
into disciplined,
life-saving energy."
So again, this capacity to
talk about our inner energies
is made much more
possible when you
see that we are body,
mind, and spirit and not
just molecules
being knocked around
by other molecules for
no particular reason.
And Martin Luther King
enlarged on this when he said
almost exactly the same thing.
"We caused no
outbursts of anger.
We expressed anger under
discipline for maximum effect."
And this is what Gandhi did.
I mean, my meditation
teacher claims
that Gandhi was one
of the angriest people
in the 20th century, but he
expressed it under discipline.
Meaning, I am not going
to put up with this.
I'm going to make
this situation change.
So he's thrown off a
train in 1893, the march
in Pietermaritzburg.
He is volcanically angry.
But instead of saying,
they did this to me,
they can't get away
with it, he said,
this is man's inhumanity
to man, and we
must do something about it.
And you see that in
the Attenborough film.
And when you choose
a constructive path,
the anger is converted
into creative energy.
You don't have to actually
know how it's happening
and do it, you just make that
right choice that you are not
going to yield to
anger, you're going
to do something constructive.
All the power of that anger,
which is considerable--
playing upon that power,
as somebody recently said,
which got us the President that
we have now in this country,
no names please.
So that power is
there in all of us.
And for those of us who
are sensitive to injustice,
that power can be very--
it can be extreme.
But if we know how to deal
with it, it enlarges us,
it advances us
spiritually, and it changes
the situation for the better.
That's nonviolence
in a nutshell.
One of the things that is useful
to know about any conflict
is how far along you
are in that conflict.
So we've created this kind
of pseudoscientific graph,
if you will, that plots the
level of dehumanization, which
is what makes conflicts extreme,
and the amount of violence
it leads to.
And generally speaking, the
escalation of conflict goes--
it can shoot up very rapidly,
especially in the presence
of a weapon or so forth.
Now, what we want to do in
nonviolence is de-escalate,
go back in the other direction.
That is simple enough.
But it's helpful, we find,
to segment that curve
into three sections, and know
which section your conflict
is at.
Partly, we'll be
doing some exercises
on this in the workshop.
In the first level, you see
the level of dehumanization
is very low.
You can communicate verbally
or through petitions
or whatnot with your opponent.
Tell your opponent we don't like
this, we want you to change it,
and they can
conceivably respond.
So the big question is,
yeah, but what if they don't?
Well, that's when you have
to go into satyagraha.
You have to resist
through nonviolent action.
And the point of that, again,
to fall back on Gandhian
terminology, is when you
really want something
important to be done, it's not
enough to appeal to the head.
You have to be able to
move the heart also.
And that is that
empathetic response
that we've been talking about.
When you conquer and
convert your own anger,
it has a powerful effect
on everyone looking on.
And what if you get to a place
where even that doesn't work,
and it's something that you
really, really care about?
Well, you have an
ultimate weapon.
Yes, I have used
that term advisedly.
You have an ultimate
weapon in nonviolence,
and we hope you
don't have to use it.
But that weapon is if you are
willing to risk your life,
it can have a tremendous impact.
I don't like this idea
any more than you do.
So what we try to
do is intervene more
at its lower level, at an
earlier stage of the conflict.
But it's critically important
to know what stage you're at.
The classic example
that I like to use
is, in 2003, they were getting
ready to wage war on Iraq.
12 million people, worldwide,
protested and said,
we don't want this.
And the then-President
of the United States
said, I don't have to pay
attention to those people.
They are just a focus group.
Terms that you're
familiar with here.
So what was he
saying, in our terms?
He was saying, sorry,
people, we're in phase two,
not in phase one.
You're petitioning me
is not going to work.
You now have to go
into satyagraha.
Even if we understood
that, which few of us did,
we didn't know how to do it.
We didn't have anything
really prepared.
The famous episode where
Gandhi was getting off
a train and people come
at him with lathis.
They want to beat him up.
He said, you know,
it's not going
to help you any to
break this head.
And he's like, well,
we want thus and so.
And what should we do then?
He said, well, you
must petition me
and then if I don't
respond to your petition,
you must undertake a
hunger strike against me.
And if I don't respond
to that hunger strike,
you have to fast unto death.
And they said, well, we're
not prepared to do that.
He said, well, then
you're not going
to change my mind on this issue.
So in the first stage,
you can negotiate,
and the techniques of conflict
resolution are what you use.
In the second phase, you
must go into satyagraha.
And in the third
phase, you must be
ready to make the
ultimate sacrifice.
All along, you can also be
doing constructive program.
Question.
AUDIENCE: So in
your Iraq example,
it was too late to negotiate,
so resistance at that point
would have been like the
soldiers just refused to go?
MICHAEL NAGLER: If you were
a soldier, refusing to go
would be very dramatic and a
correct and appropriate way
to do it, and some of them did.
But if you are an
ordinary citizen,
you had other
methods open to you.
I've had friends who got in
the way of troop trains, who
blockaded army.
There are many
people right now who
are going to Creech
Air Force Base
and protesting
against the drones.
And not just holding up signs,
but blocking traffic in and out
of the base.
And there are a couple
of hundred techniques
that are available to
us, if you went on.
Now, all of them involve
risk-- the risk of arrest,
for example.
But if you care enough, on one
hand, that this thing really
has to stop, I'm not
going to live with this,
and on the other
hand, you have faith
that nonviolence is a powerful
technique, that's what you do.
And there have been some--
the book that Nathan
was kind enough
to mention with a
little prompting,
"Search for a
Nonviolent Future,"
we have maybe 60, 70 examples
of how satyagraha has worked.
There's an eight-year
satyagraha that's
been carried on in British
Columbia against an oil
company that wanted to frack
their land, you know, come in.
They had, like, 10
projects and they've now
had to give up seven of
them because they just made
it too uncomfortable for
them, and showed them
how much they cared that they
did not want this to happen.
And that's one of the big
changes that's taking place
in nonviolence, actually.
The way indigenous communities
have been becoming conscious
of their power in organizing.
OK.
So those are the three
conflict resolution techniques,
satyagraha, and finally,
the ultimate sacrifice,
if you have to go that far.
Now, I wanted to
quickly share with you
a scientific study that Frans
de Waal, who you heard from,
carried on.
They had this colony
of rhesus monkeys.
Rhesus monkeys are
pretty bad hombres,
as you can tell from this
picture, which of course, I've
chosen for the purpose.
Here's another one.
I had to think of
this guy in New York.
"You got some kind
of problem with dat?"
So in this colony
of rhesus monkeys,
they introduced a
colony of stumptails.
Aren't they cute?
Now, stumptails are a little
bit bigger than rhesus monkeys,
but they're also much,
much less aggressive.
So the experiment
was to see, how long
is it going to take
for the rhesus monkeys
to wipe up the cage with
these less aggressive guys?
So a stumptail would
be sitting on a branch
and a rhesus would come over
and say, get off of my branch.
And the stumptail
was saying, I refuse
to put up with your
injustice, but I'm open to you
as a primate.
And sometimes,
they would actually
offer a finger to be bitten.
The rhesus would bite
the finger, which hurts.
I mean, these guys
are jaw muscles.
[INAUDIBLE] But they
wouldn't back down.
And to the astonishment
of the scientists,
within a short period of
time, this stumptail culture,
so to call it, had been
adopted by the rhesus monkeys.
So here's these
animals, they never
took my nonviolence
class, and yet
they could be reached by basic
nonviolent techniques, which
required sacrifice and cost.
But their little primate
brains were changed.
And so that was the
second big surprise.
The nonviolent
resistance was working.
The amazing thing was that
the rhesus adopted it.
And now comes the third.
Third is the winner, right?
So they took the stumptails
out after a while
and watched to see, how long is
it going to take for the rhesus
to go back to their bad
old, New York subway ways?
And guess what?
They still haven't done that.
So the conversion to
nonviolence is a robust change.
I wanted to introduce
you to these two guys
because you're going to be using
their story in the workshop.
These two gentlemen were part
of this new institution called
Unarmed Civilian Peacekeeping
or Unarmed Civilian Protection.
They were in a UN IDP camp--
Internally Displaced
Person camp--
in South Sudan, one of the most
violent places in the world
right now.
And suddenly, that camp
was attacked by a militia.
These two guys ran
into a little hut
to protect, to save themselves.
They found 13 women and
children in that hut.
And a couple of minutes
later, the militia burst in--
AK-47s, axes, sharpened sticks.
And they saw these two, who
were obviously not Sudanese,
and said to them,
hey, you get out.
Now, you know
exactly what's going
to happen when they get out.
Outside the hut, they're
listening to gunfire.
But these two showed
their badges and said,
I'm sorry we're international
protection officers
and we're not leaving.
So there's this flipping
the script, right--
intense moment of
confrontation--
and the militia turned
around and left.
Not only that, but in the 20
minutes that this raid went on,
this happened three times.
Militia came in
and said, you know,
we're going to kill
you, get out of here,
threatened them with weapons.
And these two refused to back
down, and the militia left.
Outside that little
hut, 60 people
were massacred in 20 minutes.
Inside the hut, nobody was hurt.
There's a very
dramatic illustration
of the power of nonviolence.
So that's the background.
We may be using
this story later.
So what can we do about it?
I'm just going to have to
go over this very quickly.
We have a scheme
called Roadmap, which
divides up the
problem into three
and guides you from
personal empowerment,
take us through a constructive
program, to resistance.
You can find this and
much supportive material
on our website.
But what I wanted
to share with you--
and if this works, by the
way, this next move of mine,
it's going to be the greatest
technological triumph
of this slideshow.
So wish me luck.
Here we go.
Cha.
Thank you, Marie.
So this is the inner circle,
which we've just enlarged.
And we have these
five suggestions.
You want to be very
careful about your exposure
to violence in the mass media.
I'm really particularly glad to
be sharing, with you, this idea
because I think here you can
have some influence over how
the mass media works.
Learn everything you
can about nonviolence.
You'll never guess
where I will direct you
if you want to do more of that.
Mettacenter.org.
Take up a spiritual practice.
I know Meng isn't
here anymore, but we
do have mindfulness
that's going on here.
We recommend one called
passage meditation.
It's what most of us
do at the Metta Center.
And the website
there is bmcm.org.
Stands for Blue Mountain
Center of Meditation dot org.
Re-personalization, just
be more personal with all
your human interactions.
And finally, it's
quite helpful if you
learn the basic outlines
of the New Story
and be ready to share
it on any occasion
because that's how
paradigms change.
Nandu?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just want--
AUDIENCE: They use violence
and somehow nobody gets hurt.
MICHAEL NAGLER: Oh, right.
Right.
Yes.
That's one of the real delusions
about-- thank you, Nandu--
one of the real delusions
about the Old Story
is that it's safe
to use violence.
And so you have Superman--
and this is very embarrassing
because I actually wrote
some of the scripts
for some "Superboy" comics
when I was very, very young.
I just plain didn't
know any better.
I was growing up in Brooklyn.
Anyway, never mind.
The idea is if you
use nonviolence,
people are immediately
overcome, the problem is solved,
and you don't get hurt.
Whereas the reality is that
if you incarcerate people,
they will recommit crimes
when they get out of prison
at a rate of 76% nationwide.
In restorative justice, the
rate will be more like 2% or 3%.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]